Natasha is an Iowa hi Natasha how are
you my calls certainly how can I help
well we just took the Financial Peace
University my husband and I and we are
on baby step two we're trying to pay off
our debt right and we have about fifteen
thousand dollars in credit card debt
and we have another fight from our
retirement we have another account that
we have in the market that has about
eight thousand names in it and my
husband wants to use money from that to
pay off our credit card debt and I don't
think we should
are you are you through using credit
cards yes they're cut up they're done
okay why would you want to keep the deck
well I guess I feel like that eighty
five thousand that we have you know had
it's been turning about eight percent
and I feel like these are blowing I
don't know the investment money no no
but your credit cards are below eight
percent interest no not my credit also
you would borrow at 18 percent to invest
it at eight well I mean I'm still I'm
not following your logic why is it you
want to keep this debt I don't want to
keep that I just feel concerned that
you're off of all that money that could
be collecting for retirement like being
touched up with it you know you're gonna
be fine okay you got to get rid of that
he wins you're right I'm sorry
but the thing is this the way I make
these decisions a lot of them is I just
did a little reverse engineering and say
if I didn't have $85,000 in stocks and
instead I had $70,000 in stocks and I
had no credit card debt would I go
borrow fifteen thousand on my credit
card to put it into the market and have
85,000 in stocks and the answer a
hundred percent of the time will be no
okay and effectively every day you keep
this credit card debt that's what you
did wasn't it yeah in essence and so if
you reverse engineer it it helps me make
the decision and you can do that with a
boat sitting in the driveway if I didn't
own this boat today when I go buy it no
I can't stand the thing well why is it
still sitting in your driveway so I'm
Sal
you know and that's the same thing you
just reverse engineer it if I didn't own
and I had that much money laying in the
middle of my kitchen table would I do
this again and that tells you a lot of
times that we need to shed ourselves of
stuff and simplify our lives the number
one data point that causes people to be
able to build wealth is to clear debt
become known around here for my name is
even synonymous with getting people out
of debt that's what is synonymous with
right but the only reason that is is
because it's the best way to get out is
the best way to build wealth which I
have noticed feeding hungry children is
easier when you're rich I notice any
poor people feeding anybody any hungry
kids and noticing poor people digging
wells in Haiti I didn't notice any poor
people doing stuff so poverty is not
inherently moral you're not holy because
you're broke I've been broke it didn't
make me holier it made me a holier mess
is what it made me I was stressed out
distressed everything made me mean and
mad because I was freaked out my life
looked like a country song you know
that's the way it is when you're broke
there's no nothing inherently cool about
poverty so the reason we teach people to
get out of debt is not because we hate
debt it's because we hate what that does
to you it keeps you from building wealth
which keeps you from outrageous
generosity which is the highest and best
use of money by the way